60 days ago today on this very spot a
young man petitioned the FEC for
permission to form a super PAC ladies
and gentlemen I'm sorry to say we won
everybody in there brother even Stephen
Colbert is freaking out about super PACs
an outgrowth of the Citizens United
decision in 2010 traditional political
action committees are subject to federal
limits on how much money donors can give
in election cycles super PACs allow
groups such as nonprofit corporations or
unions to spend unlimited money on
political speech as long as they don't
coordinate their activity with the
official campaign of a candidate but for
all the bellyaching here are three good
reasons not to get worked up over super
PACs in the wake of an anti Mitt Romney
documentary from winning our future a
group tied to billionaire sheldon
adelson the New York Times shredded that
the film underscores how citizens united
has made it possible for a wealthy
individual to influence an election
actually it's always been legal for rich
people to spend what they want as long
as they make independent expenditures
that aren't coordinated with official
campaigns billionaires don't need super
PACs to get their message out but super
PACs may just let the rest of us have
our say Senator John McCain's campaign
finance legislation was rendered mostly
moot by citizens united complains that
super PACs not only flood elections with
money but flooded with negative messages
McCain who lost his run for the
presidency admits that negative
campaigning works but he doesn't like
the tone yet study after study shows not
only that negative advertising works
with voters but that negative ads
actually contain more information than
gauzy pay ins to America and the virtues
of the candidates who pay for those ads
there's no question that super PACs aim
to benefit some candidates by taking aim
at others adel's in the money bags
behind the anti Romney documentary is
known to be a newt gingrich fan but as
long as super PACs don't coordinate with
candidates or official party
apparatchiks they take messaging out of
the hands of party leaders and spread it
around elsewhere in a way that has got
to be more representative of more views
of more voters super PACs are just the
latest Kaz's Bella and push for
controlling specifically political
speech in the name of making elections
fair there's no doubt that there are
loophole arising from the last round of
campaign finance reform in the attempt
to limit the amount of money politicians
would have to raise to get their
messages out but it's time to recognize
that the only way to stop creating new
loopholes is by ending the always in
effect of laws designed to lower the
costs office seekers need to spend to
buy our votes for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie